what's your name Candice I'm Ruben nice
to meet you and welcome to punch-drunk
sports where winners live when we are
live great we're live Ari we are lives
joining us in studio he runs a wonderful
show at the Laugh Factory call Ruby
Tuesday's he's a wonderful comic he's a
killer of killers
please welcome Ruben ball everybody what
up what up what up what up how are you
buddy
I'm fantastic I'm happy to be here and
I'm ready to talk so yeah I'm super
excited you and I are like probably all
the same teams probably outside of the
NBA yes
you're a I'm a Raiders Dodgers Lakers
I'm gross gross okay Raiders Dodgers
Clippers Clippers yeah now you Clippers
because you hate me I am Clippers cuz
you've been down with them from day one
I've been down with them since like
tomorrow
yeah I mean like I was I got on board on
this [ __ ] remember that Oh miles
yeah that's right whatever is here
that's right when I got here and I just
hated Laker fans and I'm all Chicago
sports except for Falcons but I'm also
Scott of sports so I when I moved here
I'm like I can't go from Bulls to Lakers
like I'm gonna get out everybody that
knows me will kill me I like I mean like
Shaq why would you want to go from
counterfeit to the original IIIi mean
Shaq's one of my favorite players of all
time Magic Johnson Kareem abdul-jabbar
the year Shaq got here's a year I got
here oh ah coincidence I don't think so
yeah still root for the Lakers they were
so friendly and fun and then when he
left it was like all the was left with
that [ __ ] garbage leader yeah so let
me ask you something Ruben well as a
Laker fan yes is there this weird thing
where you're excited for the Lakers
would be great but you know if they go
to playoffs every comedy show is gonna
[ __ ] the bad no one's gonna go watch
worse man it's like daggers even worse
than the Dodgers yeah oh absolutely yeah
absolutely when the Lakers are playing
and the playoffs when you're doing a
show I mean some gigs like obviously if
you work in the club's you work in clubs
but if you're doing like some shitty
like bar
then like a lot of the bars will not
start the comedy show laughs go after
the game so you're starting it's even
worse when they do you you ever do like
a gig and then uh then Laker games on in
the back and then like I'll cheer in the
middle of a setup and you're like oh I
guess they just hit a three-pointer or
something I did stamp in the Modesto ah
why the biggest Laker comeback ever
against the Dallas Mavericks
in the heat in Derna da da the highest
point of the war between the Kings and
the Lakers Wow and Modesto is right next
to Sacramento so they were just huge
kings and like a Jumbotron I had to do
stand up in front of Jumbotron I just
stopped and I started doing play-by-play
it was [ __ ] nuts yeah the city shuts
down when the leg shuts down is there
any team how about Yankee games when the
Yankees are in the World Series is New
York City no I mean like sorry playoff
no this it's not a bandwagon thing like
I can LA there's plenty of people here
who just don't like sports is it such a
built-up City instead of out it's not
like we're gonna have a Yankee party
that just doesn't really happen
the team's was coming in Mets fans yeah
you know it's just it just doesn't do
the same thing in the playoffs ah gates
out the gates Rubin getting dates coming
out the people comes here um we're I'm
in Houston
November 8th and 9th where you playing
I don't know I just got the date like
last week that's great I love you
where I'm and then you you know I'm just
around town right now I'm talking on a
couple co2 with your website yes follow
me
Ruben Paul comm room Paul calm I am
Ruben Paul social I am room okay next
sorry uh I got my do our at the Comedy
Store November 6 Election Day
oh and I got storytelling show in
Phoenix 27 and uh what about you what
about shooter man everybody's excited
about my favorite in November 11th in
New York at the Bell House tickets are
either great calm boom
Jason Yanni dates uh like all of us I'll
be at the all things comedy fest the
twenty sixth seventh and eighth right
that's right yeah in Phoenix so come get
that I believe our show is Friday at
4:30 Saturday is that right Saturday at
4:30 4:30 that's the live punch trunk
and that's where we are going to be
doing the live performance of Steve
Rannazzisi performing his gay porno
scene does hold on does he know he's
going to do that it's his idea and yep
we talked about it the whole time we
were at the tailgating party and people
will not be allowed to use your phones
so if you are coming to this you have to
turn your phone in no video no recording
know anything but Steve Rannazzisi will
be reacting I think the three minute him
probably well in the gay porn world
so he'll be reenacting the three minute
gay porn scene
directed by Neal Brennan that the three
of us write for him
oh that's Brennan's directing it
so come watch that and that's it suck it
dick sucked ah this Friday I am at the
Philly punchline its tinfoil hat comedy
night live at the Philly punchline
myself Eddie Bravo it's a Friday at 10
o'clock show and then
Sunday I'm back in the homeland back in
the 607 in Africa going back three one
five six oh seven two two two two yep
we're gonna be at the Syracuse funnybone
Eddie Bravo myself my mother all live
there and then I will be doing the house
of comedy in Arizona at the end of month
during my birthday and during the all
things comedy festival so I might be
popping in some shows over there I'll be
do I'm gonna try to do the punch-drunk
you will podcast yeah okay all right
that will recive and then Texas I'm
coming out there go to all all my dates
are at Sam triplea.com
I'm doing a Dallas Houston and Austin
that's November second third fourth also
all my dates are at Sam Tripoli live.com
so where do we want to go we want star
baseball I want to go to like football
let's have a quick dialogue just real
quick just you know the three of us we
got to really think about writing this
script because in two weeks we have to
have this funny a script for rent as
easy to make out with a guy and we got
to find a guy that's he's gonna be
making out with you know a local game
anybody in Phoenix area that's gay or
would like to kiss because should we
have an audition that's good that could
be a good line baby
well if live stream is more than one and
more than one guy shows up the gay ready
to make out with Steve because we went
to the bait Johnny and I went through
the the by lines of this yes here's what
it says no insertion okay no penetration
groping okay kissing okay okay so the
really the climax of this will have to
be him having a kiss with this guy Wow
so we could audition three people have
them read lines you know and then we pay
you does it also do it the way that they
do arm on Sara Night Live what's the guy
that did Nick Kroll and him and the
other guy they do the the two old dudes
what's his a Mulaney
Malena Mitch Mitch willing yeah no not
Mitch Mulaney but uh John Mulaney yeah
that's so who's the guy that would do
like the weird like emo oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah and how he was just real funny
he's so funny yeah we should loosely
script it and then throw up what they
say yeah
like write it on a card and have to
repeat what I don't love that idea stump
them yeah yeah yeah just as we go I
think you would be great today you and
our it would be really that's funny
that's funny I'm fine with that script
though right that's what it is three
page porn scripts you repay it so it's
like uh you know like a five-minute
scene it's a five-minute scene you know
so maybe we didn't have to be off do
they have to be off though I don't think
there's any way to they're up [ __ ] you
can Boyd Ari what are the local gay
comedians who don't get picked you guys
can still be on the side just kind of
jerking off I'm fine with that gay
bathhouse Kim gay bathhouse teacher I
mean maybe we can send them in as like
like Sam saying like an improv like the
pizza guy walks in now run as Easy's in
double trouble yeah you know I like it
maybe all of them get booked I love it I
think if you are gay and you want to
kiss Steve Rannazzisi and you live in
the Phoenix area
please come on dition for our big big
big movie yeah we have a title over this
yeah what should we call this sofa I
mean do we have an idea shooter -
electric boogaloos rebuilding the tower
- uncocks I say we call this 9 1 - what
you call 9 1 o the day before
Steve Steve could have stopped
everybody's too busy having gay sex
that's so funny I think that's our jump
off point right there this is September
10 let's call it September 10th uh
did he agree to this damn like Tracy
getting back at him for all the wrongs
he's done her and making her like
[ __ ] him Oh like a strap-on type
thing that game back remember he stayed
on your couch and you made him sleep in
the sunshine and with no blanket I guess
I could've opened my door let the AC
flow out but that's a waste before
before he married his wife he got busted
like you know being Shady
and then she kicked him out of the house
and then so he's like already can I stay
at your place and he's like yeah yes but
I'm gonna torture you for those oh I
think what you did was stupid and she's
a good girl and you're gonna be here one
day ari doesn't believe in cheating Mary
made her sleep he made he made some
sleep and like like a bag of potatoes
and some [ __ ]
and I'm like the Sun would be cracking
in and he didn't give him a blanket he's
like it was the worst literally it was
like being at a concentration camp you
reverse dude him didn't you fun fun
times all right yeah so we got to get
that together and let's talk to her in
the week you know the three of us have
like work to script we'll start punching
[ __ ] up and you know because that that's
gonna be nothing but hilarities so when
are you doing the drag walk Tuesday
Tuesday one drag walk one week from
today is when I want to do it are we
cool with that Donny okay so that way
excited about that what the hell is the
drag just dropping [ __ ] I all go like
that's normal hey the drag walk I'm
supposed to know that I also lost a bet
to Ari where I have to dress like a
[ __ ] and
where all the trainings are for one hour
after midnight yes to do the straw oh
[ __ ] the whole stroller yeah can you
guys hear me I can't hear me I can't
hear you after midnight we let it all
hang out I guess I'm not ever making any
bets with that matter you guys come on
man it's fun oh you don't even wanna
know what we got to do on the 23rd dude
what's all the 23rd oh we have to ship
hot dogs in a base you have to put a hot
dog
what's like each time it's like what is
happening do you want to do a bet does
it sound like I just bet for cash oh
[ __ ] wha I told you this I didn't I
don't think I told you this Ari and I
didn't tell you this look one Intel
Ruben this minute definitely not one of
my the guys I work with one of my in my
department at red zone 120 thousand
dollars on did uh I think of $4,000
parlay on all all five fights oh my god
hit all five had khabib 20 grand bro I
think oh wow three or four grand his
account was like really up cuz they bet
a day bet on football like crazy these
other two guys there's three of us at my
department uh-huh the other two they
just bet like crazy is the NFL red zone
I had a research for the red zone
channel oh okay okay so so head of
research that's right
I love it Thanks and walk around the lab
coat no no no no I get yelled at all day
long one time like last week when the
Falcons lost at Cincinnati I threw my
clipboard okay now your stuff scope I
threw my rosters I took my headset off
handed it to somebody through my Falcons
hat and then Andrew Siciliano the
hostess show goes team oh you're killing
me right now
killing me whatever it is you do go
outside smoke pot whatever it is you do
every day just come back different come
back different he says
so so for 14 years of Mike Wow
I never knew he knew I was leaving in
smoking pot every day
clearly he knows whenever you do come
back to go do that and come back
different
well I'm so mad about the Falcons in
Cincinnati why are you wearing a falcon
fat I'm a huge hockey fan
oh really yeah yeah that's your Chicago
- I am all all Chicago sports but only
because when I was eight my uncle yeah
and I Cubs yeah got touched by a cub a
soft spot for curves brought me a
Falcons hat in Chicago and I was like oh
this might be you know right when I was
getting into football and then football
cards and in Madden so you've never been
you've never been a bear so pears
sympathizer okay ha ha second team bears
with UMass football I'm really diggin
the Rams though Rams are fun Rams are
fun I'm not mad at the Rams cuz they're
LA teams I like to see him do well but
to full-on it takes a lot of energy to
root for one [ __ ] team yeah ask Ari
what his team's how you're gonna love
this oh yeah all over the teams are
Manchester United
Floyd Mayweather Floyd Mayweather the
Boston Bruins no soon as Chicago
Blackhawks I forget who's the best team
I think we'd still and the Oilers why
are you so all over the place does he
only routes for winners and the pelicans
Yankees Cowboys he's everything that
you've been brainwashed by commercials
and yeah yeah ok all Americans new
Cowboys and Trump yeah he likes the only
one he doesn't like the only weird ones
to pelicans
that's the only Apple and why the
pelicans oh dude I heard Florida's one
nightmare [ __ ] I heard the eyebrow
ones have come to [ __ ]
the Lakers I hear he wants go to Boston
he just well you know he just signed
with the LeBrons
oh that's him coming to Lakers house I'm
Farley
I'll leave what do you mean you'll leave
one yep you're gonna leave town
he comes here I'm that's it bye so
that's it I hope they doesn't come here
oh yeah you do he uh he also wants to
possibly play with Boston interesting
you here Kerry said he wants to stay in
Boston now I like that I like Boston
being a keeping that they are on them
even Boston is loaded but they have a
lot of players who do exactly the same
thing yeah yeah so it's gonna be
interesting on on how that work but they
have a great [ __ ] coach will see how
Hayward does coming back if he is an
all-star level guy you know be that's a
great worry I think so with with that
surrounded cast around them I think you
will be I just can't believe the Lakers
are just allowing a year of LeBron to go
by now we'll see Brandon Ingram he's
been pretty good in the preseason what
here's the thing yeah because like he's
he's saying that they're gonna be a
waste with your saying thanks give the
grace period I'm not saying I'm saying
they might do well but why wouldn't you
want to load up with LeBron right but
here's this is my theory on it Steph and
klay speaking of the Warriors weren't
Steph and klay the first few years they
were in the league
I mean people thought Steph Curry was
gonna be a backup rhyme to the NBA
Dorito ankles yet and they and then
these two guys these two great band name
they became superstars you know they had
a coach that you know and Mark Jackson
at the time who just infused them with
confidence you're the man etc etc and
they became stars
what if Kuzma and Ingram make that next
leap and become superstars aside what
it's possible as possible I think Lonzo
ball's gonna be great I think Saito
I actually don't I think I knew people
any any guy who can compass' and get
other players involved people want to
play with them there's always a place on
the roster for guys like he's gonna be
good bad he's
I think I don't know why they're
starting round over him maybe because he
had this surgery that everyone's like
he's moving really well for somebody
just had surgery he's like really weird
it's really weird I just think they
should have loaded up on some people
like weird was they had a chance to get
boogie cousins they didn't go after him
I don't know if these guys step up then
it's not a waste yeah I mean like I'm
also nervous I'm not nervous I'm not the
biggest Laker fam a clipper fan but like
he's got like nine shows going right now
like he literally has a show on HBO and
Showtime that's like being a blood and a
[ __ ] and they're they're buying
everything from him right now everything
yeah it's so weird yeah I hope they buy
this idea that half keep buying LeBron
all right why he look so tired you
literally look like you were falling
asleep
right he was like yeah Candace and I
caught you nodding off falling asleep I
don't know why we're sitting in front
right in front of all of your gigantic
trophies how could you be tired right
now a weight of their importance sorry
why were you up so late were you back on
the cocaine your kitchen trophies no
it's sober cock-block Tober house over
october going he hates it I hate it so
dumb so why'd you do it again
cuz I cuz my boss told me to don't
commit suicide I don't inspire them
there wastes all right he's a demotivate
motivational oh come come to my seminar
I'm gonna make you feel like [ __ ] if you
want to kill yourself or if you're
thinking about their later life or kill
yourself
I can't afford it if you can't afford it
kill yourself is the name of this
episode let's all get in some baseball
are you went to the game last night how
sad do you feel terrible I mean
Severino was awful that I mean I keep
hearing anymore up and up but they keep
denying it have you heard that you guys
that that he ended up warming
like five minutes before start 8 start
one at 7:30 - they said he thought the
game was at 8:15 I didn't hear that
that's [ __ ] humiliating [ __ ] Rondo
you know he's starting these other
pictures like no nobody warms up for two
minutes that's no hell no no that's what
that's what was the final score like a
thousand - [ __ ] - was alright 16 to 1
twice he must been loving cracking up
and I was like why are we even watching
it it's like watching legend Steve
Turner and then like he's taps and then
he still keeps punching my free time let
me ask you something were there a lot of
red Oh Red Sox fans at the game aids
they were like [ __ ] you [ __ ] just
like scream with them it's crazy how
terribly we shame people we don't throw
we don't throw beer on people we shank
you that's not yours
that just Giants fans just a giant it
says Jonathan
oh the Giants fans get shanked yeah
we're pretty cool with the other yeah
yeah you guys are with Giants fans
[ __ ] Giants fan Giants fans what do
they win three out of six yeah [ __ ] do
Bumgarner's like as much as I hate him
we win this year Giants fans still can
talk they won three Yonex Man 3 in six
years if you had a pitcher who would you
take Kershaw Bumgarner Kershaw
I love Kershaw man but Kershaw hasn't
you know he hasn't taken us to the top
yet man I'm hoping this is the year
Bumgarner he looking for a game pitcher
getting game to Bumgarner yeah what's
that buddy common Bumgarner what's his
name bomb guy you Baumgardner but barn
gun gun burner
I'm Gardner but more I like well he's a
bomb he is welcome a bump
I was but now I actively I was no no why
is it why are we [ __ ] on Sam for
[ __ ] up somebody's name you know this
is what I do
it's my hook he thinks my name is David
we've been best friends for 20 years so
you think the Yankees can pull it out
dude what you think they're done if I'm
being honest last time but he only
pitched like 80 pitches who's me rested
as far for his normal game 5 and I don't
see them taking you from Boston that's
gonna be tough yeah I mean Cece is not
will say they might win this game and
then we'll talk but no I don't think I'm
getting by Boston even if you beat him
then you got the Houston waiting for you
that's a crazy I think we lost that
playing game to Colorado yeah we would
have Milwaukee would have had to come to
us yeah I mean that would have been a
great series she swept Colorado like no
problem yeah when we lost to Colorado
I'm like yeah that's just kind of work
we're not yeah you're not because you're
not that cold we got cold yeah we just
got cold at the wrong time and we got a
top seven record in all of baseball we
had a top seven record and all baseball
but just sometimes a day you got to get
hot at the right time we got cold record
we got cold at the wrong time record
okay eight teams make the playoffs
what's up top seven record what are you
talking but look at our division though
our division was crazy ten teams make
the playoffs
ten teams 1920 makes plans but our like
three of them came out of our division
yeah if we were in some other shitty
division we would have had a [ __ ]
home-field advantage to whom came out
there just like to do yeah yeah we had
to they had to yeah everybody's you know
Cardinals fell past that guy over there
who's crying still
Cardinals [ __ ] wheels fell off yeah
that's true they came in there they ran
a train on us we said not not today
devil not today say today and we got
them today
kill them not today devil
so Houston Yankees who I mean Houston
Boston who think takes that Houston
Boston really really act man
I mean price a little better but really
he's trouble against he gets a good
hitting team
yeah with Houston I think starters man
with Verlander Berliner dismiss he's
just my ass he's he's the truth he was
at the Comedy Store the week after they
won you know just rugs like [ __ ]
Dodgers lost thanks to somebody I was
just like I gotta [ __ ] kill you dude I
went to that Game seven of the World
Series man oh I was a game too high
untrue it was I went I went to three of
the four World Series games and let me
tell you that final game was
heart-wrenching after the first inning
like all the energy but still even this
year when he pitched them he pitches
Houston tough yeah and I know why he
[ __ ] Darvish my [ __ ] these analytics
as you can see I still haven't gotten
over last year yeah and I left early
here's the I was so pissed I leave hurt
like it's the bottom and then like I
don't even I didn't even finish the game
and I leave to get ahead of the [ __ ]
traffic and it took me an hour to find
my car it was worse we play we open in a
Milwaukee on Friday yeah I are one with
Johnny to the first round and it was so
much fun fat chicks are making fun of
him for being a Braves fan it was great
it was great
did you go to Game one what yep we went
Game one I was there too yeah we were
you know it's a funny man I've always
got two tickets in the bleachers way in
the back oh no I always thought those
were the best
I said man I said hi up yeah it's not
that bad no it's actually like we got
what $25 tickets to a playoff game
oh we were high up and I was like man
this is a nice seat it's a nice seat and
the cool thing about Dodger Stadium is
if you know people like you can buy
those $25 seats and then there's some
seats in the stadium that they don't
sell and if you know the ushers you can
sit much lower I've got the friends who
are seasoned they've been season ticket
holders for like 15 years and I'm like
eh where your seats how come you're
always on field levels like hey you know
all the ushers I said bribing people
yeah and they just get hooked up on
seats I love it man now I want a door
guy at the stores yeah yeah you know
when you are well browned seven the
seventh inning the the natives start
getting restless and I'm wah I just like
to walk around like he was sitting there
I just say I wanna go walk around and
watch the wild things Rome and I would
just walk around the pavilion and just
dudes just cops running I'm seeing the
scene dude dude cops giant shotgun
bullet bullet bullet just walking
through the ops I'm like man this is
like [ __ ] scale think of your like
free stuff in the pavilion like free
guns no hot dogs or some [ __ ] don't wear
out where we like to sit oh yeah he does
his monthly food shopping there he just
loads what did they give you guys for
it's free hot dogs or some really hot
hot dogs nachos popcorn peanuts sodas
waters and something else health care
dental care free dental yeah um but I
liked it man I loved it but it's like
for 40 bucks and includes I love
Mexicans by the way I just lo I don't I
browse you're just ridiculous dude I
love them dude they're so animated and I
have these two minutes so little they
they they were gonna throw down outside
the bathroom and they're both in Dodger
gear I'm like you guys are Dodgers
you're gonna fight each other yeah it
went it went deeper than the team man
I'm
yeah they're like yo hey [ __ ] you bro
[ __ ] you bro and that's just what they
said
your turn us weave up the bathroom um
China's we pump the bathroom [ __ ] you
homeboy I'm sweeping up the bathroom and
then everybody cards its studios and
then just cops running everywhere but
don't you wanna be like guys guys guys
you can both sweep up the bathroom
[ __ ] rude it's rude what's owed you
go to any games I went to game one so
hopefully I'll go to games what three
four and five
okay which daddy's neck baseball in
minor Tuesday and Wednesday yes also
Monday is Game one Monday will be Monday
will be Game one in LA we are the first
two games are in but but Mon and twos in
Milwaukee what day what these are front
Friday Saturday Milwaukee the Friday
Saturday Monday okay good yeah they have
sunday off it's 2 to 1 1 1 no 2 3 3 2 2
3 yeah they can't that's that's way
better
yeah year yeah to go back and forth it's
just like it's too many people moving
hundred percent and baseball it's almost
like cricket man you ever watch like
cricket the games are three days long
yeah but they really are they're like
three days long and it's like that's
their series but you just play that's
they don't call it series they call the
game and it's [ __ ] nuts sorry who do
you like Dodgers Milwaukee yeah alright
[ __ ] yellow or whatever his name is I
mean I don't know how you stop that guy
I mean the kid now where'd they get him
from who I think it up Miami Miami a
Derek Jeter Darren they're [ __ ] Jeter
on their big perch of like we want to
get rid of everybody that's good than
the kid everybody that's good they got
rid of yeah I mean that's I mean they
did up what is that real sports with
Bryant Gumbel
Jeter hasn't planned the whole thing
about like gonna be like really what the
show was and they're like but no one
knows what it is yeah
oh really then Michael Jordan like when
you're the grace ever and you're just
like great analogy
it's like when one basketball players
without rap album so like I am great at
this I'm great at this - like now you're
lucky to be great at one thing to be
good at - that's why Jerry West is so
like such an insane thing yeah like to
be to be such a like historical player
Larry Bird - Larry Bird very much like
both those guys like humongous layer
birds the only person to be the Finals
MVP this season MVP GM of the year coach
of the year yeah he won all four of
those awards that [ __ ] nose
basketball that's all you can say for
sure oh absolutely I mean look at Ricky
there and Rookie of the Year
no no magic magic solo respect one of
the few Lakers our risk do you like were
the NBA's right now um just again these
rule changes in sports man has just
really killed the NFL is pretty much
dead here's the thing we're in a time
now where numbers speak for everything
but it's unfair because the rule changes
has enhanced and bloated some of these
numbers yeah you know when people try to
make the comparison who would have won
the Bulls teams or the warrior teeny
that it just depends on what rules
they're playing under yeah you know
Steph Curry playing under those old
rules he might not be able to play a
whole season because he'd be injured
being knocked knocked to the ground
every time he went to the basket but I I
agree I agree but you know it was a more
much more physical game I mean you look
at who's that young guard that was Chris
Jackson who changed his name to a Muslim
named Abdul Rahim very similar and like
got buckets
I mean Isiah Thomas now you go days
Isiah Thomas he only played at least 30
because he got beat up so bad but if you
look at Santa they just look at their
early retired you you look at but you
look at them his physical bill like if
you look look at stuff I mean he's a
tall guy but he's very slender
you know what I mean and even if you
take guys like I say even Allen Iverson
who was a small guy he was he was built
you know you have football in high
school you know and could have played in
college if he wanted to so I was just
interesting to see how these rules allow
certain there's some guys you know could
have played in any air like Jack Jack
magic The Grapes Jordan Colby they could
Bron
yeah they could have played in in the
air and I'm not saying stuff good enough
but just the freedom that they have yeah
huh there is an argument we have the
most trouble to me to era there is a an
argument that Steph Curry's the one of
the most important draft picks of all
time if you look at where that team was
before he got there and where it is now
and there is dude when Steph Curry
doesn't play that team is mortal
I agree but but here's the thing that
the Warriors did they got that they
drafted their nucleus you know the means
round you got to dream on Klay and Steph
on one team those are great drafts I
think what dream on and what clay came
in together and then Steph came like the
year before something like yeah I mean
that's just good and who helped build
that team was the great Jerry West Jerry
West so I don't know who's this I'm
telling you this - Jerry West is working
on a Clippers this team this year is
probably the deepest team we've ever had
since tribe called bench the Clippers
are good man I don't know lazy dude
people rebuilt
I hate they are rebuilding Tobias Harris
is your best player right
is that your superstar Tobias well it's
not that we have we don't have that like
that franchise player which is kind of
why they want to go for like a Jimmy
Butler if he's even that yeah but we
have depth we have scores 11 deep like
we have eleven guy SEC on any night
could go for 20 so name I'm outside of
Tobias who do you okay got you got
Gallinari
you got Williams you got a center in you
got every Bradley oh you guys got Lou
Williams yeah okay this the Gallinari
he is he doesn't stay healthy my lazy
plays I mean we're saying and we have
enough our two draft picks are both
[ __ ] great I mean they're good uh you
know uh the two centers that are
Hartzell market and whatever his name is
that kids that guys bob on what i like
him to do love that guy clipper who we
talked about bo bond elected seven-foot
o junk without junk without jumping yeah
yeah tippy-toes he's holding on but but
we should I mean Clippers they're not
gonna and they won't make the playoffs
they won't even I think they will make
you think they'll make the play I think
they can yeah I would bet you but I
don't know about these [ __ ] bad guys
do you think the Lakers make the
playoffs absolutely uh who did they bump
who was the who was the last seed last
year that was a Timberwolves that's
probably a two Timberwolves are the
family the best in in New Orleans make
it worth the Orleans was right above
them well who's the know what who's the
number one so who did the Warriors play
in the first round that's so the the
weakest team was no none of the Warriors
were number one that's right the Rockets
were number one Rock I agree with that
so what do you think about this year
what do you think adding Carmelo and
them going against Golden State this
year I like it man
I like it and listen man that for for
the smartest people the world that
Houston tries act like they are yes do
not have a backup point guard that was
insane when you know this guy gets hurt
yeah there are so many great backup
point guards out there that you could
have gotten who's the guy his name is
the guy who played up for Milwaukee last
year is that he went to Italy instead of
going to college
oh uh Brent um Brendan Jennings yeah
yeah that guy yeah he is perfect for
them yeah he's like I think he's in
Europe now that guy no he was back and
he played with hockey yeah yeah he
played walking and they sent him
somewhere else but he has an interesting
story but uh how his mom told him to
save money like when he first went he
first got his
he went to over season play came to the
NBA got the huge contract and he drove
like a Camry or some [ __ ] you know cuz
yeah mom was like cuz he's my money and
Bob you know and he was one that was out
front about it vocal about his like no
I'm not gonna spend my money on
frivolous [ __ ] I'm gonna stack the cash
but now these guys the money's so insane
and they deserve it they deserve it but
man it's so insane but a lot of them
don't understand taxes and [ __ ] like
that
I think the Timberwolves have the wrong
[ __ ] coach I said when they got hired
he's a grinder team like you know B it's
very interesting if you would have
switched ah New Orleans and Minnesota's
coaches those teams would probably both
be much better especially when they have
boogie cousins New Orleans like that's a
grinder team yeah they have like
defensive guys you know races that's
those two guys playing together what a
wasted opportunity I know dude those
twin towers together
I mean legitimate they both can shoot
the three out well the problem was is
that never well ah the point guard what
was his name the guy that the camera
column no no ha lose the truth yeah
because he finally got over his knee
injury mm-hm and then great then cousins
goes yeah it's it's crazy dude I'm not
gonna go see a clipper gaming you know
what I'm gonna get them picking my
tickets from seeking seat geek guys for
all your ticketing needs
I bought tickets to go watch yah the
Tyson Fury delante Wilder fight I got
super cheap tickets everything was for
the $500 gone for $200 each who do you
like in the fight
louder I liked Wilder by things I think
outside of him fighting Joshua yeah
that's the best fight I agree so that
about that I think that's a precursor to
that I think so but they both win that
fight and then it forces it to happen
but you go to see geek you download the
app use the promo code ponch
punch punch drunk and you get twenty
dollars towards your punch three times
like that yeah yeah punch drunk yeah I
do punch drunk and you get punch like
$20 off your first purchase Johnny and I
went to the major league baseball I'm
one to a Dodgers game playoff game 25
it's a super easy app to use you get the
app don't be a [ __ ] what are you
carrying your laptop around like an
idiot yeah get the goddamn map and
wherever you are in the world let's say
you know you go to New York and hang out
for a weekend it knows where you are and
it tells you all of the events that are
around you
it's almost social media where you can
buy events tickets to events that are
around you so comment you can go CRE to
our I think it's called the jeweler on
sonic UT there's all things comedy fest
tix tickets on there there's everything
on there it's literally the most
user-friendly app about for getting
tickets anywhere with your fake
that's the worst it'll literally it's
not just the money it's embarrassing
when the guys scanning your ticket means
like no that doesn't that doesn't
appellants eat cake all the tickets are
what guarantee guarantee whatever sing
guaranteed C keeps going insane I think
that's why the NFL stopped you can't
print tickets out for the NFL games
anymore they have to be either you have
the physical tickets that you paid for
that the team gives you or you have to
scan it on your phone there's no more so
they send you I got ran season tickets
last year before they send you eight
games you know eight yes uh-huh
art its head including preseason but
then but then you can sell those on like
some home of it I'm Ticketmaster oxy
kick or whatever mm-hmm but then like
you still have those tickets yeah so you
can scalp those but you can buy it you
can sell those like physical tickets
that are worthless because they've
already been sent out to somebody else
yeah you could if you're being [ __ ] up
and then they'll scan them yes sir these
tickets are no good yeah I'm always no I
pay my rent next season ha ha I just
yeah
don't buy tickets from off the street
you see you guys are seeking a bum
guarantee there's no way you're gonna
get scammed there's no way you're gonna
get [ __ ] and use the code punch-drunk
that gives you 20 bucks off the first
time you use it but you're going to use
it again and again and again
I mean we went we went to ram's horn ah
can we enter Rams Falcons Ren is easy
we've all used that code when it's easy
doesn't need to save 20 bucks
he bought eight tickets and we found and
it here's what's good about Tiki it's
like it'll tell you hey these are
expensive seats these are cheap seats
these are good these are bad and you can
look like put your budget in you can put
your budget in like I'm gonna spend
around 50 bucks a ticket and then it's
like okay here's all your options yeah
and I didn't you I was at work I texted
you I'm like are you at the game you're
like I was gonna text you - I'm glad I
didn't go to that guy I would have I
don't this guy singing he's thinking
it's over and it's done that was the
first game where I'm like we've overdone
for you for me and for you yeah Johnny's
going over for okay but on this show all
three of our teams are [ __ ] you're
[ __ ] are you know it all right who's
your football team Cowboys Falcons
Raiders and I think all three of us lead
on so bad we got tears what's that his
division is so bad that's where a half
game out of the playoffs right now out
of winning the division
it's just that NFC East in the AFC East
the Patriots are in the easiest division
in football every single how are they
all that dysfunctional for that long
Taylor's - yeah but no I mean when you
have the Jets in Buffalo in Miami on
your schedule twice that's half your
season that's why you're all wrong
that's why you always got to go through
New England come playoff time that
Steelers have like they're guaranteed a
[ __ ] home yeah aside from Baltimore
which is hot and cold every other year
they're somehow good every other year
but you have Cincinnati Cleveland and
Baltimore of course the Steelers are in
the playoffs every year
absolutely but at least with Cincinnati
they've had years where were you know
they're competitive you know hey um I
forgot whoa that's LeBron though
it's the same argument for LeBron in the
east like yeah if LeBron was in the West
for Moses career he wouldn't have gone
to all those finals all those times you
don't know that I do know that his
skills that for sure what team what team
would he make worse in the West no if
you took that team and put it on never
have gone yeah okay I mean like and
that's why Tim Duncan
that's why I've Tim Duncan rated higher
than LeBron they both played in a the
same size market a small market yeah but
dude Tim Duncan went through Wars to win
and he beat the Kobe Shaq Lakers to win
a couple titles I know but you know um
I'm not a huge LeBron fan even though he
is on the Lakers I'm a huge like a fan
but I do respect what he's accomplished
but one thing you for sure one thing you
have to give the guy credit for is he's
never had quote-unquote the the
brilliant coach coaching him on the
sidelines Michael Jordan had Phil
Jackson Kobe and Shaq had Phil Jackson
okay [ __ ] well that's not true
go ah uh he's had a couple [ __ ] he like
dude Kevin Love isn't [ __ ] Kevin Love is
a [ __ ] but Kevin Love is been [ __ ] Kyrie
rosin dude and they want everything they
won would come on Kyrie Irving is an
all-timer dog okay here's what I'm
saying he's never had a guy that he JIT
like like Tom Brady and Gronk we're
allies it's awesome it's been me and you
hire your ten years together oh yeah for
two years - for two years I'm saying huh
his entire career he didn't have a
[ __ ] sidecar a guy that like I can
always well let me just say this that
he's at that a guy every two years you
had a guy that he gelled with a little
bit no listen LeBron James is very much
the Peyton Manning of the NBA in that
both of those guys were insanely great
players they had too much control over
personality so it's like when you look
at Tom Brady you look at Michael Jordan
they had coaches and established thing
that could override anything they want
they didn't have the final SAP salute
and Michael Jordan had enough respect
for Phil Jackson go let him take care of
that Michael Jordan wasn't like get me
this guy get me that guy give me this
guy yeah cuz Phil didn't have to be that
guy
no but do you understand like he gets
rid of people he fires people he told
them to trake Wiggins for love now if
you look at like Wiggins skill set he
can score 20 points game and he can
[ __ ] guard people that's what he knew
it against me and then fired their coach
yeah that's that's and look at Peyton
Manning had he ran the [ __ ] offense I
mean it's like the same thing dude he
just runs the dude too much say too much
same personnel you know else's like that
but just not nearly successful Chris
Paul
Chris Paul has too much say and what his
team does I mean you look at like yeah
Chris Paul I mean he got he he got rid
of Vinny Del Negro which I agree with at
the time and he to have a last name and
he got um he got a Doc Rivers and like
you know it's like when you make a deal
with the devil sometimes you don't get
what you think you're gonna get and they
gave him GM yeah they gave him GM duties
and Dockers was his worst GM in the
history of time just look at this
clipper team now with a year and a half
of Jerry West it's a completely
different team yeah when did they get
rid of his son yeah it was great and
then they let DeAndre Jordan go it was
[ __ ] great yeah you know Doc Rivers
tried to win championship in 2002 at the
end of their players need to be coached
but players have to respect the coach I
always said the worst thing to happen to
Tony Romo is when they got rid of Bill
Parcells
cuz he would I think you'd have been a
more discus bear cells didn't play
turning the ball over throwing
interceptions and I remember when Romo
came in and relief that one game and the
media was going crazy and he in Bill
Parcells like it's one game he could be
good but it's just one game he turned
out to be good yeah but Romo could have
been great but I just don't think he had
a coach to really get on his ass and go
you throw another interception you're
gonna be sitting right next to me so you
take this call
yeah let's take a call all right let's
take this call all right he can't see us
okay why are we taking this call
should we yeah let's do not hey you're
on with room Paul hello you are on with
punch-drunk what the [ __ ] do you want
the dog at all alright good call man
thank you for stopping the show hello
Jesus I thought you were calling in the
audition for the gay porn role no no I'm
a delay it's what you were just watching
before you called the show alright go on
what's your questions bud okay this
could be the worst call ever gets vote
for worst call you said he wanted to add
to the bag of it so I want to add you on
Rubin cuz I wanted to talk to you about
some Raider stuff and that you told me
okay that you had heard a little inside
scoop possibly yes that I can't give
names but you can't give your sources we
don't ask that
okay but you had heard that the rate is
room yo source my source is 70 who's
very closely tied with the Raiders okay
his name is Tom guden sounds like good
um I'll Davis on a weed you so you know
I'm a die-hard me and Sam are diehard
Raider fans so I have a lot of friends
that are you know from Oakland involved
with the organization so when I went to
the Monday night game when we lost to
the Rams when we dominated in the first
half hours half champs two games this
year you won the first half so you know
you ever coming out of five yeah if you
have a couple of drinks sometimes people
loosen up so this one guy that you know
we kind of hit it off with before the
game I said man can I ask you something
he goes what man do you like slow
dancing
what the hell happened with Khalil and
he was like dude and then he he told me
he goes look he goes in February before
a training camp the draft everything
started they offered they offered Khalil
twenty one point five million dollars a
year 51 million a hard guarantee and I
think 80 million overall guarantee it
was close it was wasn't too far from
what he ended up I mean he got more from
the Bears obviously but he didn't even
return the Raiders phone call and whoa
and that's when Gruden kind of was like
okay there's there was no negotiation
that's the thing and this particular
source was like I've been telling mark
why don't you go public with this why
don't you everybody's known it out he
wanted out when it or he wanted to wait
he he wanted to to no doubt be the
highest played defensive player and then
when Donald thing came that's that's why
he waited the whole thing out their
whole thing was like yeah we're gonna
wait that happens a lot with people
where looks like if there's like two
greats like let's say three quarterbacks
are waiting for a contract you know it's
gonna be one two three highs played
quarterback Heisman and they break each
other's records yeah so and that's what
happened with a with an Rogers he just
waited for Ryan to get his contract just
walking her carving it it Scott cousins
to get his contract and her like wins
Rogers gonna get it so it's almost like
they're like Aaron Rodgers was like I
clearly AM the best here so you guys all
go record break record break record
break and then I'll start negotiations
and i thats what he did no he didn't he
said that sassy too like this he knew he
knew Aaron got exactly right here and
Donald was like he is probably the best
defensive player other than me yeah so
when Aaron Donald's contract and that's
what's happened Le'Veon right watch
sorry go to sleep everybody I mean if
you're tired nothing better than a dog
no I let me make a button let me make
this point so for them to even offer our
contract it's not like it came as a
surprise that
you're gonna have to try to sign car and
Matt the Raiders knew this all along
they made the best from rola so they
made the best competitive offer they
could make at the time knowing that the
money was gonna go up as time went on
and the Raiders are broke that's why
they're moving to Vegas people forget
that Mark Davis is the only
quote/unquote broke owner in the NFL
they parked cars in the end zone and
it's it's a that dude they make no money
they have a horrible Stadium deal they
rent they don't get I don't think they
get any of the concessions that are
being sold at the stadium Mark Davis is
broke man and Jerry Jones is the one
who's broken here at that Stadium in
Oakland so Oakland is some money I mean
Vegas is a money grab for him they're
finally gonna be able to do we playin
the worst stadium in baseball
dude it's yeah I mean it's the people
who make the stadium Mike Davis and I'm
a season ticket holder so but that
stadium is a dump dump
Davis gets his hair cut at super bad
cuts so and he's the nicest guy if you
ever meet Marc he's like dude that works
at at Ralph's bagging groceries he's
like the news I was like yeah yeah he
carries himself like that we know so
interesting - your teams are like that
like the buses aren't rich they their
money is the Lakers they don't have a
side business for whether the buses are
rich no the bus is like comparatively to
the other other owners like most of
these guys are views names are their
side [ __ ] yeah like they own a
construction company and then they have
that team dude you know I'm our owner is
part of the Council of 300 dude he's
like one of the richest people on the
planet
Stephen ba Ballmer like he was on the
floor all Allen when the guy I get what
you're saying but I'm saying the buses
are rich but the rich too mean you not
to that not to the other Oh America to
the world but not in that 928 owners 27
oh yeah whatever they're like they don't
have a side hustle yes like oh you only
have one helicopter what a [ __ ] trash
heap you are
yeah Mark Davis that he can't complete
the money like there they're talking
about the Jaguars possibly relocating to
Oakland and the whole thing was in
England yeah and then the whole thing
was like well you know they can build a
stadium for the Raiders why would they
build one for the owner Jackson was
because he doesn't need your money he
can build the stadium himself he has the
money to build it himself like that show
Jackson San Diego I can't remember his
con yeah like he's loaded yeah soccer
teams yeah he looks like he throws
damsels on train tracks he was talking
about building a NFL team in the sky
that's how it is he's just like he's
like I own this guy now I don't know why
man Jacksonville is a decent team it's
like you know if you look at say just
they need a quarterback man boy bortles
is because he's great in college like ya
know he was beat he's going to a small
school beating big chance but he goes
against your theory yeah for sure but
somebody like I think what happens to
some of these guys who were good in
college there's no wide receivers
anymore either
Jacksonville yeah maybe they're two
starting wide receivers it was a
Moncrief yep the one
yeah they don't really have any any
studs yeah but I think it yeah I think
the speed of the game affects some of
these guys when you come from like
there's such a jump and athletic ability
from college to the pros like some of
those passes you can complete in college
are guaranteed interception all of these
rookies and there were five of them all
of them are playing really well yeah
well I think the system is set up for it
good fences are going good yeah [ __ ]
the the guy from USC at the Jets is
playing great yeah the only one in
Buffalo but I'm like that I don't even
know if that's his fault
I think he has the biggest skill set of
everybody well I think what we're saying
now the reason why a lot of these
quarterbacks are doing well it's just
sleeping it's just the sign it's just
the sign of the times like 20 years ago
you know from Pop Warner to hi
school the offices weren't that much
different then you made a little bit of
a jump to college and then the NFL was a
whole different world now you're running
pro offenses in high school I mean these
kids are playing they're going straight
onto like camps to learn yeah do all
this [ __ ] so there's so much more
prepared to come to the NFL because
they've been playing in pro systems and
learning the terminology back when
they're in high school so that's the big
difference that you have now I think how
is it and then the rule change is on top
of that I have a question for everybody
including re talks because Hari was
taking a nap gonna say we'll get new UFC
just finished we have no we have 30
minutes left in the show and we haven't
talked about this UFC fight yet that's
my question to me I know I'm about to
quit the show we've talked NBA the only
sport in my life actually in the regular
season yet it's all we've talked about
enough let's get in this UFC basketball
is year-round
yeah but you love what happened to it
UFC so this is I love I like I have all
these theories on it oh rogon said it
was a Mar on the sport and everybody
that was watching in my [ __ ] fight
party was like this is the best thing
I've ever seen in my life I was the only
person from punch drunk at the punch
drunk [ __ ] fight viewing things I was
Johnny wasn't there you weren't there
I'm the only one at this [ __ ] thing
work at my dick off and it was the
greatest thing I've ever seen well first
of all went nuts first of all that
happened first of all the event that
night that we threw was a huge success
your success packed we're gonna keep
doing it it's a great thing to do I had
a wedding to go through and you know
these items who are about 70 bucks I've
ever spent my life time Sam's forgotten
about a wedding totally forgot about a
wedding
well my girlfriend's like we're going to
this wedding right
I set right before his set he shows up
in a suit and like where are you yeah so
I had to get there but it was huge
success they can't afford to do it again
but I would love to go Eddie Bravo put
out a funny meme that said you paid for
a fight and then you got mad when there
was another fight I like the notion that
like here you know what the UFC is
getting better at like hiding how
they're full of [ __ ] like you remember
when Brock Lesnar went in and pushed and
everybody in there like rape that's not
how you pipe a [ __ ] like the dragon uh
be nobody would be laughs and they're
like yes they be doing Stevens easy gay
porn acting in that [ __ ] nobody would
be [ __ ] laughing right so it's like
now everybody's like this is a Marne
sport that save Connor yeah that now
people want to see that funny machen and
I love how when they asked Rogan and all
these are the feel about rematch they
were like what what do you mean why he
lost so clearly for four straight round
I think a rematch goes exact same way by
the way yeah yeah he'd get destroyed it
goes exact same way he looks so bad well
but I don't even know much about UFC and
I didn't I knew what could be yeah
that's gonna win that fight just when
when you look at their skill sets on
paper what each of them can do like this
guy clearly way more fighting for two
years you to work on your wrestling and
be great in a war liar several times I
believe he's been exposed
yeah and it's all about his gas tank to
me you saw how exhausted he was in the
the Diaz fight Diaz fight he was gassed
in the Diaz fight and then when he got
tapped he just like I want out of this
same thing in the mayweather fight just
yeah that's around eight or nine year
old TAS and he still would have gotten
his ass beat
no he doesn't have good cardio that's
what I'm saying
he just doesn't yeah here's the thing
dude he looks like you can see it in his
face when he's like am i I just want to
be on my yacht that's right
he didn't have to a choke he literally
named rap you could just see it he's
just like I'm 42 like this only it's
like UFC you must have worst at setting
their stuff they love to set their stars
up for failure they never give them to
like Bellator you can say whatever you
want for Bellator they love putting him
in with tuned with [ __ ] tomato cans
boxing does it all the time tune-up
fights to nuts like to throw Conor
after two years off into their witness
can hardly hold on argue Lee be called
the go at this point no but here's the
better fight they should have done
Connor versus Pettis and then Ferguson
versus could be because that was gonna
be a fight before and if ferguson loses
it doesn't hurt the brain you know III
think what they were setting up the odds
I think the Pettis Pettis fits into his
skill set I think what they were setting
up was they desperately wanted Conor to
win this fight Diaz to win on November
7th and then the trilogy on January
whatever [ __ ] you don't Diaz and
Connor trilogy as they're super cash-cow
and that's the Sandcastle they were
building I think now they're gonna do
this rematch and he's gonna get his ass
kicked in the rematch [ __ ] about the GS
trilogy everybody's talking over each
other what come on they're already in
negotiations for it it's so annoying
he'll do whatever for Connor and what
sucks it was no one else to ruin that
brand what setup the rematch wasn't the
fight itself which was boring
it's everything that happened after the
fight setup there which is so gay yeah
it's not really gay I mean that liked
the most offensive way to gay people
listen listen uh it's just the UFC is in
deep [ __ ] they can't they they're
failing up they keep cell
laying and making up what Oh totally
Fergus did not get a title shot because
Damien why it was six months Dana White
jumps over dollars to make times because
my girlfriend doesn't know who Ferguson
is that's why and I don't even have a
girlfriend but said girlfriend doesn't
know who Ferguson is and knows who
Connor is and knows who you know and
Connor and his boat are you saying he
was stripped immediately immediately
dude that's bogus
hey well but well here's the fact most
fighters only fight once or twice a year
anyway
yeah the sunglasses on inside long tail
I mean like there are some good fights
on this card the Isle of Skye was great
that fergus the fight was great the UFC
is UFC is like comedy clubs who thinks
it's the comics job to fill the room
yeah and then you blame you for not
being but even though they could make
way more money than you absolutely and
that's really where we're at right now
and there they are they have a marketing
problem the UFC they they don't know how
to market their stars they don't know
how to do it they what do you mean dude
yeah but Connor did that the UFC doesn't
know how to make stars the NBA knows how
to make stars the NBA you know like look
at Donovan Mitchell in [ __ ] Utah I
mean like the dude you have [ __ ]
small market teams that do really well
because the NBA is much better at
marketing do UFC has no clue how to
market people they [ __ ] rely on these
guys to talk [ __ ] to get people
interested and it's just like just you
know there's some great fighters you got
to be active you got to be pushing these
people and it's like there's some great
fighters that nobody goes watching us in
because the UFC doesn't know [ __ ] you
know how to market these guys what did
you guys think about the melee after
yeah I was gonna say but do you agree
that that was hilarious oh it could be a
bit Conor I love it
I like to be now he's got I don't yes
shady people and his [ __ ] absolutely
they're like real gangster no they are
like straight up Dagestan you know he
wasn't playing any games he was like the
manager is a former terrorist and that's
a proven fact come after you with the
bus was because Kobe these guys cornered
one of the Conners guys and beat him up
with a baseball bat yeah yeah I don't
[ __ ] around dog yeah
I don't [ __ ] around dude but there's
great fights and just like now you know
it's like Ferguson what a grand investor
when he took his pants off and he goes
why did you take your pants off and he
goes my balls were hot that's what means
you have see great before these crazy
crazy characters man crazy [ __ ]
character this deal with the ESPN's
gonna blow up in their [ __ ] faces I'm
telling you right now the end ruins
everything they ruined baseball with
steroids the Rooney NFL's with these
concussions the chart retards hitting
free throws they ruin everything I'm
talking about oh this guy
let's [ __ ] a guy hit a free throw they
just put him in the game now you got a
[ __ ] make this a whole [ __ ] sweet
story [ __ ] yo E TMZ SPN I thought that
you thought that what he did after was
bad when we were texting who could be I
thought it was a black eye on the sport
why is he the black guy for the sport
where did black eyes uh I mean is that a
real yeah I mean he jumps over like that
there's children there's families their
children
civilian could get hurt net any civilian
could get hurt dude it doesn't go past
the fence it was all UFC and the corner
people there's a thought it's Vegas
Vegas has a thousand cops everywhere cuz
every single one of those casinos are a
bank they're giant bank and they have
thousands and thousands of cops right so
it wasn't gonna go anywhere
it's spectacular it is they are trying
to take out with a time in the outline
I'm bagging all sports
yeah damn in it's all cops and just
people that should be punched then I'm
in I don't condone what happened but
Connor caused that to happen cuz Connor
can jump in the Bellator ring and like
attack people so like he desserts is way
worse that's what I mean copy that
Gordon any other fight card him like
that son cause of fighters was worse
than this white athletes hanging out
with Drake is the equivalent of black
athletes dating Kardashians it's never
gonna go it's never gonna go well and
always practices that on stage right I
mean like everybody walking out with
Drake you're a Jew do dude that's a girl
I do this vu do nobody does well I mean
the Toronto Raptors right so they've
killed our black athletes yeah dude the
Kardashians are they're witches and they
said it's black magic dude Drake dated
Serena Williams was she bad then yeah
probably
now she's really never been bad no she's
pretty much but I don't I don't I don't
put Drake in the Kardashian category no
kardashian lamar odom man Lamar Odom
living a good life on yay Kris Humphries
what happened here Humphries oh nice now
Blake Griffin is in Detroit right now
because the and then they had the player
on a like interest in Thompson's
interest there was a receiver for the
Cowboys lost yeah yeah Reggie Bush into
this career Reggie Bush my Miles Austin
had like a Pro Bowl year and then just
disappeared
literally disappeared they bring so much
attention that you can't focus on what
you're supposed to do and when when
Blake Griffin started dating a Jenner
the Clippers like nope nope nope we put
up with your stupid-ass sketch show with
Neal Brennan okay we said that was all
right we let them [ __ ] go you're damn
Jenner that the exact words we put up
with your cisco committee of 300 meeting
and he's like dude you're dating a
Jenner that is voodoo there's never been
a team that does well when the [ __ ]
there Dana Kardashian look at the
Houston Rockets I have analytics or
analytics of the Kardashians right yeah
break it down dude I would like to [ __ ]
every single one of them including Bruce
and just give you guys like a
play-by-play and be like hey my life got
better after this one your luck never
like will your life will get better
what's up your life would get better of
course if you [ __ ] a car - oh yes his
life would get better your life will get
worse yeah I see who you [ __ ] your life
would get worse Kourtney dated that like
twenty four-year-old each she took him
all over the world tell you there's a
couple things I know and I know the
Kardashians vagina tastes like [ __ ]
sherbert all right if there's anything
they take care of with all the money
they have dad alone in my life will get
better
what kind of great what kind of sherbert
I'm thinking strawberry maybe sherbert
orange I know you've every new pair of
it tastes like butthole sugar I'm in
there but holes probably taste amazing
as well yeah there's no way they don't
have a team that works on those holes
that's all they do
team hole oh boy just going the word so
I don't know like these guys make so
much money like why don't why not just
sleep with them they don't have to you
know to make them your girlfriend
because the people the people in their
in their ears are telling them that this
will get them the exposure to
getting even bigger contracts to get
bigger shoe deals and it's just like and
they you just dance with the devil man
you dance with the devil their literal
witches I don't mean that figuratively
they are literal witches they are into
the Voodoo to black the color schemes
all they are dude they're [ __ ] black
snake charmers yeah that's what they are
well they go to a club and they sit in
front of a basket and they play a flute
and some black Boehner like a globe a
cutout that's that is so [ __ ] up
Black's make sure look at the track
follow you down strange times dude
strange times yeah I don't know what the
UFC's gonna do man if they set up listen
if they what they have to be they have
to be like we have to make all this four
billion back now because that's the only
reason they would make the counter fight
immediately when they realize he's he's
completely out cat black here's my
promises from it everybody knows how to
beat him just take him down just stay
away from the punch and take him down
yeah that's why I think pass would have
been in better fight he do that with a
champion if he loses two fights in a row
like this the next one let's say you're
supposed to be the best you learned your
way up he's not some actor trying it
yeah but people need warm up fights it
happens all the time but I don't think
he's gonna get one yeah I don't think
let's say Connor let's it kind of loses
his next two fights you're done yeah but
that oh you guys don't give I'm saying
that's why you throw them in with people
that Pettis but hasn't been the same
since he lost I'm actually agreeing with
you I'm actually agreeing with you I'm
saying because Connor has had the belt
for two years and there's been in terms
since that so technically he didn't have
the belt be tidy clean Ferguson should
Ben been that fight Anthony Pettis has
not been the same fighter since they
started doing stringent drug testing him
Johny Hendricks who's retired they
haven't been the same fighter it's a
much better fight
Kyary lost the key beep so if you go or
if he loses the [ __ ] - uh - pedis
it's ok because you still have that
cabbie fight down there if he puts a
couple wins together Sam it's also a
sport you can't just take the top guys
and be like don't let him fight each
other no no time in boxing they give
these guys a couple people to walk like
one maybe to warm up fun well you know
you don't get time off 150 million
dollars in one fight but you know it's
interesting this is a the difference
between UFC and boxing in a nutshell I'm
a huge boxing fan I'm starting to get
into UFC but one thing that I major
difference is every [ __ ] fight in the
UFC is the Superbowl like they instead
of spreading them out nobody good yeah
you know and and one thing that that the
boxing does they know how to build
fights and I think that's what Sam is
speaking to is you know they'll keep
certain fighters away from each other
for a certain amount of time to build
value and then when it's a big event
it's a huge event it seems like every
UFC fight it's like having eight Super
Bowls in a year it's like only after a
while the Super Bowls not gonna be the
Super Bowl right and that's just me from
the outside looking in 2014 belts in
boxing and there's one belt new UFC they
should have more belts yeah are they
good because there's so many more
fighters now that similar fighters like
me either 5 pounds or 10 pounds of
course whatever and another thing that I
find interesting and you're talking
about marketing is you know you you have
all these great fighters in UFC but the
purses don't even match up to boxing
purses and that's about boxes which is
really interesting for a sport that's so
popular yeah well that's you know I saw
sports it's only 20 years old basically
I have a theory that we're a country of
workers and we are we don't like seeing
workers get shams you know and screwed
like why did Walmart okay we're given
because people stopped going to Walmart
because they knew they weren't paying
their there their employees as much dude
an NFL why
I think a big part of the NFL people
like these players are getting [ __ ]
yeah by these owners we're country
workers the UFC I think that's a real
big problem for them right now is we see
these people these fighters do in these
huge fights walking around with like
walking out with a couple hundred white
like Dana White who is a wonderful
person when I met him he's been nothing
but a gentleman and he's a businessman
you got be a shrewd businessman but the
fact that Dana White makes more on a
fight than the guys who are fighting I
have a problem with that yeah why I
don't know as to that extent well then
you have a problem with all major sports
I listen the owners in baseball but the
baseball has a wonderful union and they
get paid very well that union is insane
what the UFC fighters are become have
become bigger because they're in the UFC
whereas boxers you can just you can just
fight on your own if you want there's
separate promoters yeah but you don't
get big unless you play ball Eve is the
right promoter you get on show good
point on that's a good point Ari made
that I never looked at so USC in itself
because you're involved yeah okay almost
don't get it you they made you the name
because if giving you the [ __ ] like
being in Bellator is like being enough
like I like the [ __ ] Arena Football
League
it's the biggest card and they put the
karate hottie who's like a number eight
ranked fighter with a like pusher and
make her bigger right now by giving her
eyeballs yep and that's exactly what
they did and they're like she doesn't
deserve all that we deserve a lot of
that for making well you know it's it's
you know what you're seeing right now is
like women it's kind of like women were
you know when Dana White says hey I will
never have women in the UFC and then
five years ago or like whatever Ronda
Rousey came in six seven years ago you
know now they're in it so it's like
there's a like kind of a vacuum of like
hey anybody who wants a fight any chicks
wanna like if you start boxing right now
you could get in the UFC if you have
[ __ ] played your cards or who's the
hottest chick that can take a punch
yeah karate hottie her nickname is
Crotty hottie well how about the other
chick who came you know like they're
waiting in her
no well here she's number eight in that
division she's done more magazine covers
than anybody else in that division
yeah yeah that's exactly right yeah yeah
well I think I think with the women it's
such an anomaly to have women in that
particular sport that it's easier to
market them because like oh look at what
women aren't supposed to do they're not
supposed to fight she has great tits
she's pretty let's put it in a magazine
look people doing more of etiquette at
it kick like a tit kick would be like a
don't move if you were fighting a woman
I don't think but does it hurt when you
get punch okay so why don't they do that
right now let's see what happens that'd
be great it just explodes like a cow hit
by a car
[Laughter]
do they wear do they wear like what are
they wear what do you mean what's that
don't they wear like biker shorts
well they dress like they're swimmers
from the 1920s sometimes what's the
story there
all right put on your old [ __ ] 1920
swimsuit yeah all this stuff hurts it's
like we can't kick you in the balls like
what our vaginas hurt - it's a bone so
if I can hurt I'll kick in their [ __ ]
right the old [ __ ] can't but if you got
kicked in the vagina that I met when
that would hurt right yeah kick anywhere
probably all right what are you doing
right ball kicker pretty much stuff
anybody here for a moment of time I will
I'll go straight up Krav Maga and punch
somebody to nuts in a heartbeat I don't
even give a [ __ ] I'll bite you in the
teeth
I'll buy tragic right now you know I
always yeah yeah
how come I haven't seen that I'm
WorldStarHipHop to thread to the world
star babe I tune the teeth you're right
like there was a time in my life where I
went to WorldStarHipHop every day and I
haven't been there forever
yeah did it go away I know the guy died
the one dude died of one of the owners
of a today oh well that's more than no
that's what that's a great brand I
literally went to there all the time why
did you hate it because it's one of
those things where I wish it wasn't
exposed to the public because it's to me
I was just like finally there's a
website where there's a lot of parking
lot lights is it will sorry hip-hop the
equivalent of like Fox television's
where it just shows you the worst of
your people absolutely no I get to
absolutely I never thought about that
yeah cuz you're not black you wouldn't
have to I I thought about that but I
kept watching of course I mean I would
watch too
I just wanna watch a crackheads jump off
the hills it's this the war you know me
my first say this is like gonna where
I'll start hip up this is the best worst
[ __ ] ever that's what we say this is the
[ __ ] worst but we can't stop while I
used to call it Burger King fights calm
man cuz it's always like a fast food
chain it is empty calories entertainment
like I'm not doing this bad to pregnant
chicks at a McDonald's throwing I'm not
that and my life's not going that bad
but what's so you see some [ __ ] up
things about world well you know what
now is like and I did I talk about some
stage about nobody breaks fights up
anymore oh no we're too busy [ __ ]
getting their phones out yeah that's
true back in the day like I was doing a
show in Ventura at the Ventura Harbor
comedy club I broke up a fight at the
Vikings Rams game let me tell you
something if I get my ass whipped on
camera and my friends were there I'm
[ __ ] all my friends up yeah like dude
your your man and then you're more mad
house and then the guy you punched yeah
it's like absolutely give my ass well
that's a great mood and help out you
didn't stop a fight between two complete
strangers at Vikings Rams when we're
leaving
and this and this guy's like behind us
and he's so annoying and I could seem
congrats though he's a younger guy
younger guy I get it yeah we're all kind
of like making fun of him and every at
the end of every corner we would all
switch seats cuz we had eight seats in a
row uh-huh
miron is easy bunch of everybody can
hold hands with each other so just like
I don't want the same dick in my mouth
for for court all right but then so when
we're leaving this guy that was you
could progressively see him get drunker
and drunker and drunker you know and
we're all kind of like making fun of the
same guy and then he's getting it now
he's like getting into a fight with
somebody at the end of the game and I
literally had to like just separate both
of them cuz I already talked to this guy
several times separated I'm like hey
give me the speech you gave to them to
realize that they're all just people on
a planet hurling through [ __ ] space
and that they should just love each
other
what was your speech let me hear you've
had too much to drink you've had too
much to drink
can I borrow 20 dollars my biggest fear
my biggest fear was like cuz you're we
were way at the top way at the top
somebody is like yeah or not throwing
off that way but just like push somebody
where everybody's leave it's like it's
bowling ball yeah like a bunch of people
get hurt did you really stop it
I've got in between them yeah I used to
be the break up the fight guy Yusef and
I got in between you know all those
fights all the time like with the
hairstylist with that haircut he just
his new haircut like it you don't like
it you hate it I like it actually like
no I'm joking oh I think it looks good
for him you had a mohawk yeah it's a
weird look I like it no it didn't I had
a gut you can have a mohawk and at god
it's just a bad look I'm just talking
about neck up isn't like Fat Mike though
isn't yeah I guess right he's been doing
it forever it's bran but when you have a
mohawk and a guy it's like Anarchy if I
could get off my couch I'm a lazy [ __ ]
you know it's just like it's a bad look
it's a bad look I mean body down yeah
but neck up yeah I thought it'd look
good on you
um I could not have a mohawk you and
Nick pull off good what do you wear now
you just I mean he's got the Hitler
haircut Hitler is called Coleman so it
looks like I have full head of hair you
know you you won't go bald you think
LeBron's a she Asian who man is positive
that he has been on steroids
since he was 13 no I listen let's look
at it from a different perspective not
just me as an athlete nowadays
especially if you're competitive it
would almost be impossible not to be
doing something I think I think they all
are to a certain extent I think they
tested the NBA just like they just NFL
you telling me no players in the net and
if they were using steroids at all are
you know it's a saying here's the thing
man if LeBron failed they would never
tell you he's too important it's like
Tiger Woods I have an opinion that Tiger
Woods is probably back on the sauce and
nobody would ever bust him because he's
too important to tennis he's drinking I
mean sauce
Oh juice yeah song he's back on [ __ ]
HGH whoo he said Tiger she's offended by
that she's so offended by that disgusted
by Tiger Woods is important to tennis is
that the name of the episode I mean when
he wanted a Johnny guy amount of people
that were following him when they did
that set that wide shot of the like oh
yeah and it's like the whole tournament
was following him
he's a catch he's the kind of oh really
he's the kinda McGregor of golf all
right what was what does that like man
all right looks like he's in a horror
movie right now holy [ __ ] go ahead guys
I'm alone and I'm scared huh so like so
like I'm sitting at the I think the 12th
hole par 3 on the greens and it's fine
it's like whatever and then it starts
getting busier and busier and busier and
then as Tiger comes up you know about 15
when they knew he was gonna win what the
15th hole they knew he was gonna win
so everybody converged on him from 15 to
18 yeah he was talk about a tournament
that he went to oh yeah okay yeah I'm
saying so he tees off on three and then
starts walking and everybody else just
starts walking while players are trying
to tee off
there's cranes are moving holy red like
300 people moving and these other guys
like wow wow respect off would you say
exiting of course what course did you
see him plan that was TPC Avenel in
outside DC wow that's cool about to be a
cool experience were you walking and
following him or were you know 12 was
pretty cool approach shots real close it
was a short par-4 where people could
drive the green so we were just kind of
watching there for a little while I feel
like the par threes would be a fun one
to just drop cam time oh yeah yeah you
just kind of Walker it's fun you walk
around you find some shade you're like
Austin here for a bit
it's kind of it's really kind of fun but
on Thursday we're sure we went oh nobody
else yeah oh that's fun it's kind of
cool I had no idea I was such a big
sports man oh I couldn't go watch golf I
bear low I could and it I would want to
go see Tiger just to exchange just it's
a nice stroll in the park
that sounds really oh that's a mark
while people hit golf balls in front of
you as any one ever knows that Tiger
Woods and
Steve Byrne have the exact same voice I
never love I can't I got to think of
Bernie's voice a kid it's the exact it's
the exact and one day they let you burn
that's also his Irish impression his
Conor McGregor impression and his real
quick way to start doing comedy where
yeah I started here in LA
we're at the laughs fact no first place
I ever went on stage was a place called
the Birdland West in Long Beach and it
was hosted by DL Hughley and it was the
Congo this is the Apollo this was in 95
and it was like the Apollo of the west
coast of the west coast like you would
get boot that was your first fight yeah
cuz uh one of my boys at the barbershop
used to say man you should do comedy
should do comedy do comedy I didn't even
know that there are places where black
people did comedy and they used to go to
this place every Tuesday night and it
was jam-packed he's like yo I know the
chick who runs this place I can get you
five minutes and I put it off for about
a year that's a lot of time than when
you're starting yeah I put it off for
about a year but then you know everybody
in the barbershop started calming like
you come in here every week and you talk
[ __ ] you should least give it a give it
a try you go hang in a barbershop is how
to do when you know you get a haircut I
mean just generally no yeah you [ __ ] if
you go get a haircut like save save I
took you to a barbershop me and you'd
show up now and you probably wouldn't
get into the chair until 4:30 I don't
know why we just sit and talk [ __ ] and
you're sitting there like dude I gotta
go I've been in here since [ __ ] noon
can I get my hair cut so is this one of
those things where we would catch up
current events discuss politics that's
why the ollie they're trying to do all
these themed type shows around the
barbershop because in the community is
such a big thing but fast forward and uh
to the Birdland I went I watched just to
watch that I'd never been to a live
comedy show at the end of the comedy
show DL just comes he's like shaking
hands he comes in he's like hey man is
usually the show and my mind was gone
why the [ __ ] did this guy come up to me
it goes
yeah I'm actually thinking about doing
comedy goes you should do it pass me on
the shoulder then takes off then maybe
six months or to you in your life there
I was a twenty five okay and at that
time I was working at Delta Airlines and
I happen to be working with his father
at Delta airline Wow
it was just a crazy how everything just
kind of mixed at that at that point I
remember I had went and did did comedy
with him DL kind of told me the places
to go and then one day I'm at work and I
get called out of the bin and it was DL
father dinos father's like hey man I
heard you doing that comedy stuff and I
go yeah and he goes you might know my
son I go who's your son he goes Daryl I
was like ah I don't know any arrow and
he goes oh you might know him as DL I
said DL Hughley is your son so I go to
the break room I called the L and the
phone was like yo do I work with your
dad
he was like [ __ ] you work at Delta I
was like yeah that's just wow that's how
it kind of came and then he he mentored
me like the first part of my career but
that's why I started and I didn't I
didn't do a mainstream room until like
almost three four years and to doing
comedy I was just scared to I didn't
realize it and then DL was like hey how
come you're not ever at like at the
store at the Laugh Factory the improv
and then I said I don't know man I don't
know if they'd get me in in diego's we
barely get you killer
Thank You Man and I ended up going and
um started working the other rooms but
it goes back to what I was telling you
growing up like we never I never went
north of Wilshire for anything you know
I just stay in the South Bay Area Long
Beach is a wonderful comedy town yes
because this wonderful Long Beach has
gotten like every year or two
Long Beach gets hipper hipper hipper
better better better
yeah like the train then the train came
down and they well first I had the
[ __ ] what's that big-ass Queen Mary
Queen Mary's and that became cool and
then now the train comes down there and
loop
it comes all the way back like it's slow
long beaches a hot spot to me
well Long Beach is the only place I
think that's close to Hollywood that
makes you feel like you're on the road
when you perform there yeah it's the
first one yeah you feel like you're
doing a road gig it doesn't feel like
you're performing in LA when you
performing in Long Beach you know that's
really nowhere in the valley that gives
you that same for you now does give you
the same distance yeah
but the valley just feels like you're in
the [ __ ] valley yeah but Long Beach
makes you feel like you're somewhere
else
when you have then you think like that's
what prior recorded that one you know
his best special to me was he recorded
at the Long Beach Tears theater yeah
Patti LaBelle open up for him it's no
big you have to be to have Patti LaBelle
open your comedy special if you have to
make a bet on who's the biggest comic
ever who would you have it I mean
socially we understand what Richard
Pryor did in terms of a five-tool player
who do you thinks the biggest and if you
had to make a bet would you use bet Diaz
I bet the aside for all your bed needs
that's right go to bet the s I use punch
25 get $25 betting cash what god dude
I'm passionate about bet the aside dude
that's your Segway yeah five minutes
yeah okay but are you talking about
skillset like who I feel is overall or
just that they put up numbers I mean
when you I mean there's just so many
things to take it in context but I mean
Eddie Murphy has the highest grossing
you know stand-up movie of all time
he grows 50 million dollars for a
concert film in the 80s that's insane
for comedy think about that a comedy I
put a hundred people how crazy was it
everybody listen to it there's no more
biggest comedian in the world there's
big comics Russell you know yeah but
there's no more the clearly is the
biggest one in the world yeah and he was
he was everybody knew about everybody
know about him and then I think after
that
we'll discount this like after any kind
of faded away of course Steve Martin had
his run but then dices
the biggest in the world exactly yeah
and then Dice Clay had a [ __ ] huge
run you know at that period of time when
he was did Madison Square Garden and
everybody's like who Kevin Hart fentanyl
well as far as right now if you're
saying biggest comic in the world as far
as numbers it would I mean it would have
to be him I would think but like like
Ari said there's a lot of comics doing I
mean Sebastian is doing for Madison
Square Gardens you know who are Square
Garden for corridor god that's that's
insane but you know but then some cell
at the bathroom stall the bathroom at
Madison's well one of the most
incredible things I've heard as far as
my I mean Kevin did Madison Square
Garden twice in one night so that means
you feel an arena empty it clean it and
that's where the passion is doing as oh
you and Friday and Saturday to show and
that's that's crazy that's crazy you
know and then you know you take somebody
there's certain guys who can do arenas
in certain markets right now Kevin can
do an arena in every single market and I
don't know anybody who's doing that
right now if your time on right now guys
use the code punch 25 where does that
get you Sam $25 Ben cash free [ __ ]
money what I get free [ __ ] money 25
$3 and whatever you put in extra guess
what they do they match it they double
it I throw 50 bucks in they throw 50
bucks in now you have $125 to bet with
where you only put $50 in and here comes
our locks of the week Ari
oh we talked about it the other day yep
we talked about it on Sunday night you
and I were talking I am four and one on
my locks of the week
ari what do you want to know yes
he just started doing it and yeah I know
you took your loss week four
because you were three you know first
half and then I your oh and two first
half yeah haters yeah so the first half
is going on
yeah what is our locks of the week ari
do you have one I gotta find the ads I
will go with here comes my lock of the
week ooh
bears dolphin what's the spread
bears dolphins I don't know what the
spread is I almost don't care what the
spread is who is who's Kansas City
playing Kansas he's playing the Patriots
on the road that's going to be a hell of
a game that's a hell of a game
only because they're playing in New
England New England and dude they're
just so smart yeah hello Chuck we'll
have something planned for a three and
two a three and two Patriots to me is
like an angry rattlesnake snake in a
corner like you you know you're just
like oh I don't want to [ __ ] with that
if Kansas City could get pressure on
Brady I'd have more confidence and
there's Sarah missing defenses awful
stars Seahawks Raiders I'll wrap it up
what do you got Seahawks riders well you
know I'm going my writers they better
not lose that damn game to the Seahawks
I'm gonna go with I'm just gonna
randomly throw someone out there
Denver put his number play I'll go the
opposite way
I'll go Rams friends are playing Denver
Denver yeah off Rams Broncos teams
locker the working week the one against
they took against me
what's up your one loss on lock of the
weeks last year last week was the one
you you bet against me me no no now you
didn't you take against then you take
the Rams against my lock of the week but
I went against the Rams
no I didn't oh oh Rams Vikings I took
Rams Vikings that week that's the game
we went to but they won but then last
week when I said lock of the week was
that Rams would not cover against
Seattle and you're like Rams will cover
against the oh yeah that's my loss yeah
okay because they won but they didn't
cover okay yeah yeah all right guys
consider it sucked bro
great meeting you man thanks for MRE
I can't wait to you're in the studio and
a cup
weeks nanny arm all the way here talking
this in you bro thank you suck it